A 50-50 .
ANA LOSEWITH USLHTHTLY.
>> THAT VERY TELNGTAE REPUBLICA
FACT.CONTRO TE RIGHT NOW
.THE HISTORE CONVENTIONAL
ARE HOUSE,
BU IG IN
SENATE IS A DIFFERENT AND
FASCINATING STOR
AND WE HAVE HARRY ITUSALK UST A.
A BETTINMAWANT TO  IN VEGATH
YOU.
BUT TELL US,T'S GOINON ITH SAT
>> THROW THOSEICE GO OVER AND L
CHAMBER CONTROL.
TH RT IT WHEN WE'R NEXT
IN THE HE CONV
WISDOMS BACAS ARSTRLY HEAVY FAV%
NTT CHAMBER.
THE SE, BASICALLY 50-5
IS NOT SOMETHINGHINK EVE
DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE EXPECTED AT
>> DEMOCRATS WOULD
HAVE EXP
DNAND I THINK THIS JUSGETS A
ING WE'VE SEO FAR,
WHICH ISKNOWIDATES
IF WE LOOK, IFASICALLY
AT THEDIFFER-- GET
REPUBLICARRUNNING. LOOK HEREY R.
HEELRGIA, RO
ISCONSIN, DR. OZ
I.EIR NEBI
THIS IS THE
THEYAL
E DEMOCR
OS ILAR --VEDEMOCR
CANDIDATES ARE MUCH
BLE.
IN GVE A PHAEL
CANDIDATE GO OVEE OWAN S
AT THE TRENT
SEHAVE.
THESE
LOSYAN
N'
LEAD., USOINTS OVER
N JOHNSON.
>> HERE'S THE OTHER THG.KING AB
THAT JID
HE OTHER REAS ARE IN
GOOD ABOUT WHAGOING ON I
WO LOOK AT ALL THE SEATT ARE THT
ROMNEY W OY DOUBLE
OKGITS.
OFM.
E CLOSER THAN OTHERS BUTIS I DI
GROUND THAN I THINOF PEOPLE AREO
EPUBLICAID
ONLY NEED TO ONE NET SR TO TAKE
SENATE.O JOE
WHE  BE JUSTTO MAIN THE STATUS O
IN THIS SE IN PAUL?
>> YEAH.
SO W BACK
OVER TIME AN
AL
MIDTERTEPARTY HAD NO NETS INURNU
UNPOPAR IDENTS.
THE REPUBLS SEATS IN 2018. 198RM
AGAIN.
H.PPENED HERE  THIS WAS POST-9/
STILL, I MEAN, J
CUENPOLAR THANLS
ALAPPROVALG IS
THIS CHA SHOWSRE'S NOT
THAT NECESSARY CONNECTION
BETWEEN ANESING.
T'S THE CASE
THIS TIM
>> HARRY, K SO MUCH.
WE'LL BE WATCHING ALL OF THI